hello sorry bags mark just had a stroke
no what do you meant to say was today
the show later on I dropped a new
trailer we're gonna watch a Blade Runner
trailer and hopefully having a reaction
that big Oh
Elizabeth this is the big one Fred
Sanford today got fat man on that man
[Music]
[ __ ] the Batman Batman I'm Kevin Smith
I'm not dead yet our very lives still
with us folks we're gonna watch the new
trailer for well is it a trailer it's an
announcement Warner Brothers was calling
it look pull this leg and it plays
[ __ ] jingle bells I was born Friday
but not last Friday you call it an
announcement that's what they did it
Warner Brothers if you look online it
just says Blade Runner 20 what is it 49
20 49 announcement not trailer but it's
the minute and 46 seconds of footage
from Blade Runner with music behind it
and dialogue in it which means if it's a
trailer if it looks like you know a duck
and quacks like a duck and you can [ __ ]
it like I said I'm gonna do this to Ben
it's a [ __ ] duck I think this is a
trailer kids I mean we didn't try to
[ __ ] it but it was a trail yeah it's not
like a trail it defit yeah we've already
watched it but I'll be honest with you I
didn't understand it at all
so we figure we watch it together Marx
and obviously much smarter storyteller
than I've ever been
maybe he can shed some light on this now
is this is a sequel it is a direct
sequel who is Ryan Gosling meant to be a
new character he is meant to be a new
blade runner' Blade Runner was the term
in the original movie for people who
hunted rogue replicants who went off
their programming see so he's the new
harrison he's a new Harrison Ford and
the old Harrison Ford is also in this
movie who was directing this picture uh
danny film in what else did he do he did
a rival oh then he could [ __ ] take
all my that he'll have my money I'll
have my attention
I [ __ ] love a rival we haven't done
it oh right well let's blow it for a
little bit right yeah yeah [ __ ] a
rival movie is probably the best movie
of the year
I love rogue one quite a bit but you
know it's a fun fun movie movie and
stuff a rival is one of the most
brilliant screenplays I think ever
written if it doesn't get a screenplay
at least not but it should win this year
there's no justice in the world this is
a [ __ ] brilliant writing
I cried journalist I say much I cried
during everything but it's an emotional
[ __ ] family it's not about what you
think it's about like they sold it to us
all as
invasion movie which it is it's not not
bad yeah but it is it is that tricky
thing that science fiction can do that
almost nothing else can do which is its
spectacle about something it is
breathtaking and even thinking about it
I start getting emotional the movie was
so insanely well done now it too was a
movie when it was done I [ __ ] pause
the movie and turn to my wife and was
like help I just explained it please and
when she did I cried even harder it was
him I got an emotional bang out of it
but when I understood the exact science
of the storytelling it's breathtaking
what a high-wire act this poem is like
it manages to both be a full-on legit
alien invasion movie a movie about
communication and like I saw this movie
on like November 3rd or so just as we're
in the throes of political discourse and
fractured country and election City to
see a movie that's basically about how
we can talk to each other and how that
munication communication dialogue
learning a language specifically not
just like hey let's talk to each other
but like they had to learn a language in
order to like solve the riddle of the
movie which was so much bigger in the
movie itself that's trying to keep it
vague because the movie is a [ __ ]
mystery like I'm like there is a twist
that lands about 20 minutes before the
end of the movie or for some during this
afternoon why because oh that's why she
said that
no but it's one of those things where
like you know we've seen movies or twist
endings before and they're all well and
good and some of the works of them don't
but the mark of a really great twist
ending is that it reshapes the front
half of them makes you want to instantly
rewatch the movie - because you're like
oh it quite like I even said to my wife
afterwards it was like it had a sixth
sense kind of ending where I instantly
wanted to go back and watch it all
through a different filter it is like if
film you know is essentially sleight of
hand a magic trick this is one of the
greatest magic tricks I've ever seen in
my life because they keep you focused so
on this hand that you don't understand
what they're actually building until
they bring their hands to
gather and you're like oh and then your
wife explains it to you credits roll if
you like oh my god that's it brilliant
I'm gonna cry all of the team after that
it doesn't I'm good this movie was after
has done my wife explained it to me I
literally said this to her I was just
like you know like most times I don't
really like I'm not saying you're done
but I don't think of you is smarter than
me but in moments like that like I feel
like maybe you could be smarter than me
like of course I'm [ __ ] smarter than
you I'm like I understand is like you're
supposed to be as my wife but seriously
oh thank you maybe [ __ ] smarter than
I think and it's weird cuz I'm doing
this job like the job where like I'm
asking somebody who's a film watcher to
tell me how maker they did what they did
[ __ ] crazy it's a it's a wonderful
[ __ ] flick and not just like the
screenplays brilliant yeah but
everything's great what is it
Eric Heiser ur good Irish kid yeah um
but the direction by Denny miss you who
is directing this movie yes is exquisite
because he it is a visual visually told
story and he shows you he shows you the
car that's what's such a magic trick
about it he literally just like any
magician shows you all the cars and lets
you pick the card and put the card back
in and [ __ ] when the trick happens
you're like he showed me yeah it was all
there's all there
I just wasn't smart enough until my wife
explained there were parts in the Hat
it's a magic yeah and so like when I
heard that Denis Villeneuve was
directing Blade Runner I was subtly
interested in Blade Runner I would you
know what I've agree with that not that
like we all love sir Ridley Scott but
like we've seen him do Blade Runner yeah
um and I loved seeing where he goes net
like [ __ ] Ridley Scott won't quit
[ __ ] the Martian yeah like that's like
that's somebody's like yeah I made that
movie and now I'm going on something
looking on I'm saying it wasn't his like
working the whole life to tell this
wicked story like he's like just another
one hey I did that Friday now I'm
working on this now I'm working on
aliens
yeah which is out in May I think we saw
the poster for it badass
oh but any event you know I'm actually I
agree with you I was more interested in
like oh let's see somebody seek was and
he's still involved he's got a gold
production credit on stuff so the guy
doing it that's my [ __ ] respect not
only do I love a rival but I loved his
other two yes Rogerio and prisoners
occurring discards yeah this guy's good
okay so we're about to watch the trailer
and you're hopefully going to watch us
watch the trailer mmm
for Blade Runner which I like coming
into it was like yeah but now after that
discussion I'm like pumped up because I
like this director yeah any other thing
that I like about it is that Blade
Runner and we've talked about this
before I think even on the show it has
this like almost holy place in cinema
history yeah it's a Citizen Kane of
sci-fi and even I would go beyond sci-fi
just modern cinema yeah like it is this
sort of landmark piece of film that for
me isn't that good as a movie it's
beautiful like it's important because of
how it looks it's important because this
dismiss you know it's probably like
probably better you do that I'm with you
I'm not with you but I understand what
you're saying it's not like you know
this movie is always like quite like
Citizen Kane people like this unparallel
this is the best movie that's ever been
made of its kind they put it in the like
la Piedra putting a top 10 like there's
a sight and sound like 100 greatest
movies of all time list they put out
every 10 years but in Blade Runner was
always on it he's absolutely right but I
don't know that it has as much to do
with oh I love the story
no like cuz if you ask anybody you know
a man was the story of Blade Runner like
lemaise my watch it's just my own
personal but to be fair they've been so
many versions of Blade Runner yes that
got taken away from Ridley Scott by the
studio who then took a bunch of stock
footage left over from The Shining to
end the movie it's a movie like when
they're running for the hills that's
basically the footage of they go home in
credit driving to the Overlook it
literally has Blade Runner ends just
wrap it right into the opening of the
show
like as if that family looks up and sees
a flying companies just like Redrum but
uh yes yeah like it's a movie that we
remember from moments and for images
more than we remember because it's a
great story
hmm you know wake up time to die
yeah or you know I've seen things you
people could watch the Taurus it was
that boy contest that's it yeah I wonder
if I could pass that's what my wife
called me test yeah you could uh I know
no doubt it good idea and then all a
sudden [ __ ] our support busting
brains me with that space-age I remember
seeing this movie when I was a kid I saw
this in theaters so I wanna hear [ __ ]
from people going look presume history's
[ __ ] dick filmmaker I get it on all
those things that being said I saw
[ __ ] the theatrical loot opening week
because I was a huge Star Wars fan I
didn't go for the Ridley Scott but I'll
be honest with you it was [ __ ] nine
years old I was gone for [ __ ] Han
Solo son so I was like we gotta go it's
it's Harrison Ford who plays on Soho and
he's in space but it's not Star Wars my
parents were like fine were gone he's
got a dog he's got a goddess I'm as good
as a pistol ain't no lightsabers our
walkies but I might as well be strong
with my man cuz it was between Empire or
Star Wars Empire were yeah yeah I think
I remember Empire early the year before
Empire circled Empire mmm I'm sorry love
big time a [ __ ] hand job solo now the
entire Star Wars universe
so I demanded we all go see it and
there's an r-rated movie oh yeah you get
to see the joini Cassidy yeah now get to
see something good see son but my
parents you know the end of it my
parents are like that wasn't good didn't
worry my parents they didn't see the you
know the way that most people did but to
be fair a lot of people when the movie
came out did know business and anything
it grew into its exquisite reputation so
sequel izing Blade Runner all's going to
take huge stones
huge stones but also like you have free
reign to tell a story in that world
because the story previous in that world
nobody remembers
good like they have love for it but they
don't really remember why
beyond holy [ __ ] that looks amazing
that's what the future looked like on
screen for 40 years is blade runner's
feature but that story it's just it's
film arts it's overheated warmed up like
Philip Marlowe privatized [ __ ] it's yeah
very detective story yeah which I love
just better
what will this new one first off I'm
gonna London I need to say in a
complaint but that's the title Blade
Runner 2049 what year did Blade Runner
take place it um cuz it was our future
we've already hit I think yeah I want to
say where something like 2012 over 20
some maybe even like 2002 I mean have a
feeling it was like not like 24,000 yeah
it was like 1999 said Los Angeles this
is 20 49 mm so maybe it was like 20 19
they're saying this is like 30 years
later she's gotta be like thirty right
yeah Lange Gaza mm-hmm
okay we're overthinking this [ __ ] this
is where I watch the trailer and analyze
it thusly
yeah fair warning I've already seen it
once you've seen it I've seen it once
just today though don't know what's
going on hopefully mark could be my
temporary wife and explain things to me
we'll figure this out
and we press play
smoke looks like the future all right
that's heresy boys boys yeah
definitely not Dawson's voice although
that's Gosling so this look like street
sweepers in the cold mmm that what it
was that's maybe a lot of company
credits up for it does that meant to be
sand or snow first small Mars
it could be Mars from where did the
first one took place on earth right yeah
Los Angeles but they have reference to
like offshore mining for this image this
[ __ ] glory hole face I recognize it
from the movie why uh they're building
that had that in it thing so that might
be the Tyrell headquarters perhaps yes
now what is this is this a cop shop what
is this where's this Tyrell headquarters
that's not Tyrell hookers you know looks
like the bank from inside man yeah it
does um in the CheY CheY yeah CheY yeah
CheY yeah I mean this is I remember that
from Blade Runner touching moon who'd
hack
Larry
so
is the M right now that looks
Bladerunner II totally there you go
there you go all poco ad that looks like
waiver um let's see these credits like
them i buy so fast
yeah okay what i got out of it this time
was he thinks Harrison Ford's a
replicant so he showed up to kill my
guess is that he is on hunt for other
replicants but needs the Harrison Ford's
guidance to do so because Harrison Ford
was the best of them the best Blade
Runner we'd ever seen so in the many
versions of Blade Runner they've made
there are some that imply he's a rep
that Deckard was a replicant indeed I
don't know get that feed out of this or
no I don't but the thing I get out of
this is the you know one last job like
bringing the old dog to teach them young
dog some old tricks more than I'm
hunting you down because I'm pretty sure
that you're dead because he couldn't be
a replicant aged right replicants
weren't supposed to get open never get
older and they'll never die like the
kids in cocoon yeah I don't know I mean
they talked about like the Rachael
character and that first one played by
Sean Young was supposed to be the
replicant like the next version of them
and she would age and I think it was
that she was going to like that she was
a girl she grew up she was going to get
older she was going to die like that was
the next phase of the replicants was
simulating humanity down to the wire
it's gonna be interesting to do a movie
about replicants in the wake of
Westworld which has taken the idea to a
[ __ ] new extreme and stuff and and
you know is about as quasi futuristic as
Jeff Bladerunner
you know they don't have the giant
cityscape with flying cars but some go
on some futuristic going on in was world
although we haven't at all seen the
world outside of that Della's park in
West world yeah so they could totally
have flying cars and laser beams and
robot servants in the whole shebang
there's a guy filled with hope there are
a new hope rebellions are built uh I'm
in but like you know not not like God
might why I got to see this know like
you know oh yeah I guess let's go the
one thing but the one honestly what's
going to get me to that theater more so
than any of the footage I saw is just
that directors
I mean that direct I respected money
from non-semantic that guy in working
with with Roger Deakins who is one of
the great cinematographers of all time
true like and that's say what you want
like that [ __ ] was beautiful I was
beautiful like that dude knows how to
expose an image so expose an image is
dirty yeah well good way to slip nip
slip something yeah so all right I'm in
like I'm a mark for this [ __ ] anyway but
you know I can't say like yeah it is not
like isn't really a term Wow yes nobody
can say that you gotta go back Marty
yeah it's your kids it's I'm there but
it's that that trailer didn't like
[ __ ] blow me off I guess I'm
cautiously optimistic I mean they they
you know they showed you what you needed
to see ya wanna see Harrison Ford how's
this work holding a gun see here it is
I'll go yeah [ __ ] it that's a lock Tober
I got time to play again I'm but I'm
going cuz [ __ ] Denny been you I know
he's a goddamn genius whose name I just
huh I'm so like Ryan Ryan Gosling quite
a bit
did I see the la-la-land not yet I'm
about to you so yeah he loved it I loved
it my kid saw an Instagram Bananagrams
text me a photo her like ballin really
ugly crying and she was like I loved
that so much that she loved la-la-land
the the last 10 minutes of la-la-land
actually have a lot in common with the
last 10 minutes of arrival really and
you will know it when you see it now
you're gonna make me watch it sooner
rather than later I'm a Gosselin mark I
I like I like him in almost everything
I've seen him I like that
[ __ ] movie he was in what was it nice
guys oh my god with Russell Crowe I've
watched that movie 3-4 times almost now
it's a funny legit fun to me legit funny
movie I didn't see in theaters but I saw
on video caught on iTunes as a [ __ ]
dope and he's funny
like stair guy he's always good on SNL
and I think he's funny dude I think he's
he's he's that thing that that Justin
Timberlake is which he's a performer mmm
but he can also act like that's I think
Timberlake doesn't have yet Timberlake
can't oh well you saw Holland yeah oh
that's right that kid was in Mickey
Mouse Club yeah so he could prize a
hover he's got a little hoof he's got a
little saying he's got a little
I never thought of him as that because I
just think it was such a serious part of
that like that wid class with the Taemin
Timberlake increasing Aguilera and
Britney Spears he's from the same group
I think yeah there's some cast photo I
think that has all of them in it Wow
yeah god I'd hate to be part of that
group where you're like yeah I'm not of
those four people why would he do a crab
shell on my manager KFC's is the best
one in the state so do you want a famous
bowl what would you rather have a I used
to be famous Bowl I was never actually
famous pool or the Mickey Mouse fish
little and you're famous for a minute
and then other [ __ ] become more
favors of you like gods with men jerk
would you like I'll take two famous
bowls and we can have this conversation
wouldn't it be nice to be famous again
ball oh God I have retainers in it I
want that ball but then people tell me
you never were famous to begin with a
good point I'm going on there it is
folks man [ __ ] we're ready we're
ready to receive Blade Runner [ __ ]
2069
is it is now called 2049 2016 ow that's
an arc of the boiling [ __ ] like that you
tell your girl like I'm gonna take you
to see Gosling in a 69 you gonna get 69
in the car on the way to see it or
she'll leave you for Gosling call me
marketing department long is on a poster
they're sure at some point there will be
a film called blade winter 2069 if I
know the internet the way I know the
Internet
you're gonna see one of them fast nine
of them ah there it is folks for fat man
I'm Batman I've been Kevin Smith and
I've been mark barnard come back next
time and we'll talk some more [ __ ] at
yet same bat-time same bat-channel smart
guess calm or youtube.com slash Kevin
Smith
[Music]